Україна без олігархів та без корупції.
Цього вимагають від депутатів
мешканці наметового містечка біля Верховної Ради.
Народні обранці їх наче і не чують.
Напередодні Україна опинилася за крок
від втрати безвізу через законопроект,
який міг зробити діяльність першого
незалежного слідчого органу по боротьбі з топ-корупцією
повністю підконтрольним правлячим партіям.
Директора НАБУ Артема Ситника могли просто звільнити
за спрощеною процедурою, більшістю голосів,
а діяльність детективів стала б відкритою для зовнішнього контролю.
На думку нардепа Сергія Лещенка,
поява відповідного законопроекту свідчить
про початок активних дій напередодні виборів 2019.
Влада хоче підстрахуватися
аби корупційні розслідування НАБУ
не завадили учасникам передвиборчої гонки.
Нічого не помінялося в частині еліт,
в частині їх ідеалів і принципів.
Тобто вони заточені на особисте збагачення,
на корупцію,на своє як найдовше перебування при владі
з метою збагачення, з метою корупції.
Для цього є певна риторика,
яка не збігається з діями.
Тобто на словах за Антикорупційний суд,
в діях влада це саботує.
На словах- за ефективне НАБУ,
в діях - намагаються НАБУзв’язати по руках і ногах.
Законопроект через тиск суспільства,
нардепів та західних партнерів України
поки що відклали.
Натомість парламент звільнив
голову антикорупційного комітету Єгора Соболєва,
який активно боровся за незалежність НАБУ
ще на початку його створення.
Я вважаю, що мені видають грамоту
від президента Україниі корумпованої більшості Верховної Ради.
Зараз Соболєв іронізує, але, насправді,
він переконаний, що не лише західним партнерам України,
а й українцям час консолідуватися навколо захисту НАБУ і САП
та вимагати від влади більшого:
виконання обіцянки щодо створення Антикорупційного суду.
Якщо ми йогозробимо і зробимо по-справжньому незалежним
велика частина парламентаріїв сяде до в’язниці
разом з оточенням президента
і разом з самими президентом.
Тому зараз боротьба не на життя, а на смерть.
Або ми топ-корупціонерів, або вони нас.
Без Антикорупційного суду - НАБУ і САП
не можуть бути стовідсотково ефективними.
Якщо парламент буде і далі намагатися зробити
НАБУ підконтрольним, то це буде означати
лише одне – підозрювані чиновники уникнуть відповідальності,
заявляє на своєму сайті керівництво бюро.
Такий зухвалий тиск на НАБУ,
вважає народна депутатка Світлана Заліщук, буде не останнім.
Я думаю, що точно далі продовжиться кампанія проти НАБУ.
Цілі залишаються.
Можливо, інструменти змінюються, а цілі залишаються.
Ми будемо бачити, як публічно
система скоординовано
буде наїзд на Ситника,
буде можливість вибити його з крісла в іншій спосіб.
ОпитаніDWдепутати переконані:
якщо влада не змінить свою політику,
то Українаможе повернутися в часи Януковича.
І вже наступного року доведеться не про якість реформ думати,
а про те, як зберегти хоча б те, що вдалося здобути.